hello everyone and welcome to a most
interesting game from round eight of the
isle of man chess tournament it's a
Dobby Danton we have our versus
Alexander Grisha and it's just just a
very interesting game that really shows
you what kind of a what kind of a person
Grichuk is and I mean that's in a very
good way so without further ado let's
check out this very nicely we also do
have two fresh photos of the players too
that you see on the left here players
profile photos courtesy of John Saunders
one of the official photographers of the
Isle of Man chess tournament so it's
always a very exciting that we when we
get to see what the players look like at
the moment of them playing the game so
without further ado let's check out this
very nice game guitar with the white
pieces opens with c4 so the English
opening is on the board we have a five
by three shook g3 preparing the Finca to
the light square Bishop Knight to f6 and
brush up to G - we have Bishop to c5 by
three shook and now Knight to c3 and we
have c6 preparing d5 by Black Knight to
f3 preparing to castle and now II for
not allowing this idea forcing the
Knights to move and there are the
disposition hasn't been seen much in
top-tier tournaments now there there are
positions where Knight g5 was played and
they were nice to g1 was played but the
movie ro place is nice to h4 and it is
already as almost six that we have a
completely new game at least regarding
top tier tournaments so Guri show
continues with d5
striking in the center and here Aggie
Haro trades once see capture see
captures in the d3 again attacking black
center now and here Knight the g4 by
Grisha yes we do have a lot of horsing
around here but with good with good
cause as the f2 point is under attack so
of course you have our castles here and
now Grisha has to make a decision
III is a very interesting idea it seems
like it prevents white from further
developing but after something like F
characters and Bishop captures with
check of course white will not recapture
you're gonna see King h1 and now after
d4 it seems like black is really
stifling White's development but
actually white has my
- f5 here and here really it's just a
completely crazy position where anything
can happen if you captured the knight on
c3 then just Knight captures and e3 is
possible also Queen to a4 check it
becomes possible because after we
capture the Knight Queen a four check
can also pick up this Knight the g7
point is under attack so everything is
really crazy here and although it seems
like it gives a lot to the black it
actually favors white even Bishop
captures on f5 I know a lot of your
current considering this still just the
rook captures on f5 and the white
doesn't have a worry in the world still
you cannot capture here because of
Quinte for Czech and now after you block
nice to d7 year you're still capturing
Queen captures in g4 now again your g7
point is hanging your bishop on e3 is
hanging and the white will just be
winning here now so III a very
interesting move you could play it but
you have to be very careful and Grisha
chooses a very different line g5 he says
your knight has nowhere to go so how do
you how do you save the knight it's
actually a really really tricky idea
first d4 you push away the bishop with
Russia back to e7 and again what do you
do with the knight first h3 now you
force the black knights to move it or
that or you can trade just captures
captures the problem is if you go Knight
to f6 then Bishop just captures in g5
it's not a problem and on the other hand
if nice to h6 then just Queen b3 you
completely ignore this threat because if
your pawn captures then you lose the
night on h6 again now the problem white
will be much better here
so after h3 grisha decides okay Knight
captures an f2 oh why not
we have group captures on f2 and then
now G captures on h4 and here we have
Queen to b3 just attacking the d5 pawn
and the black will have some problems
developing it you can't play something
like Bishop to e6 you lose the b7 pawn
and good issue already grabbed grabbed
upon so he decides the first H capture
sin g3 he will grab another pawn rook
the f4 and now Knight to c6 he gives
back the d5 pawn with Queen captures on
d5 and now as the f7 point is under
attack
Bishop defends it with f5 and everything
is perfectly fine here for black
but here white creates some problems for
black well not really but it all depends
on and how black will react in this
position here guitar plays Bishop
captures on e4 and now Grisha has to
make a choice does he accept the
challenge with F captures on e4 and I'm
sure you are expecting him to accept it
as it is the title of the video or does
he just say okay I get back at the pond
we just continue the game queen capture
special characters and so on the
material on the board is equal we just
continue we're playing a nice normal
game but Grisha decided that f captures
on e4 is the way to go and he accepts
the challenge so what's what's the
follow with Queen to h5 check first of
course you force the black King to go
for a nice walk we have King to d7 and
now again you don't want to do some any
unnecessary checking like Queen to a5
check because after King to c7 you will
run out of useful movies you don't have
a check here you don't there are no ways
to continue this in a good way so here
black would actually be better so here G
Hara does what you have to do as white
bring all of your pieces into the attack
Bishop to e3 clear the C file for the
rook one of the knight moves you want
your rook to completely cut off the king
from from reaching the the safety on the
Kings side and okay we have Queen to g8
by Grichuk not preparing Queen to g6
he's up a piece so he wants to trade
Queens of course with d5 by buggy Haro
now attacking the knight here and Knight
back to d8 and Knight captures on e4 you
have to bring the knight deeper into the
attack and also you do want to clear the
C file for the rook as soon as possible
and here gray ship goes Queen to g7 g6
and now offers the Queen trade of course
once you've sacrificed a piece around
the attack you are not interested in
trading Queens so Queen to e5 now not
trading Queens centralizing the Queen
also the rook on h8 is under attack so
there is one movie that comes to mind
Knight to f7 it defends the rook on h8
also the Queen on e5 is under attack and
the white needs to make a move so you're
around yet the attack you don't want to
go back and allow black to consolidate
here gr o just continues the attack
rook captures on f7 not only getting rid
of the threat on the Queen but also not
the rook is threatened with Queen
captures on f7 and here the situation on
the clock is Agee Haro 21 minutes and
grease shock one minute and some 40
seconds of course that doesn't surprise
this group is always in time trouble so
what do you do here Agee Haro
about to make a move so a lot of
interesting moves here d6 is an
interesting move rook to f1 attacking
the Queen is an interesting move could
you capture the rook on h8 that is a
good question for example if you capture
the rook yes you've grabbed the rook but
there are maybe some other moves here
after Queen captures on d5 perhaps black
will get a chance to consolidate it's
still hard to develop white would still
be of course much better here but D Hara
finds a nicer move you know extra points
for for aesthetics here look the c1 just
a nice slow move preparing rook to c7
not only that it also cuts off the
blocking from escaping
here we have looked f8 by Griff shock
saying okay if you try to do some rope
lifting or something like that I will I
might have Queen to f1 check and if I
get Queen to f1 check it's actually mate
because the HT to point is covered by
the pawn so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the winning idea
for gr o in this position while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
creator of miniatures in top tier
tournaments and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show if you found
Queen to c7 with check you will not be
winning this game after king to e8 there
is no good way to continue this attack
you are just down material for example
if these sex is just Bishop to f6 and
black is perfectly fine and there are no
move that white could use to create some
sort of an attack and d7 is covered you
cannot put these seven you cannot trade
Queens your queen is under attack and
well you still can't move the rook
anywhere since it's just gonna be very
unpleasant but for those of you who
found rook to c7 that's a much better
line although it requires some
calculation for example you have to go
back King to d8 and now you have to
force yourself to play a slow move in a
very crazy position because now Queen to
f1 is the threat of mate but now just a
slow Bishop to f4 you prevent Queen to
f1 and now whatever you play pretty much
will be winning and of course you have
to notice that if Queen captures and i-4
than just Queen captures and if Sonny 7
is made but it requires a lot of
calculations because when a slow move is
involved you have to check everything
that black can do and it tends to be a
bit unpleasant so after Luke to f8 there
are a lot of nice ideas d6 for example
is also a very nice idea but it requires
a lot of brute force calculation for
example Bushell characters on d6 Queen
captures with Czech king he ate and now
Queen to e5 Czech Queen blocks and now
Knight to d6 with Czech covering the f7
square you're going to go King 37 and
now rook the c7 with Czech getting the
the defender of the Queen away from the
Queen King character so now you're gonna
capture the Queen with Czech and of
course the the the rest is
self-explanatory but the Hara didn't
play any of that and for those of you
who found the G hardest move you also
get extra points for creativity and for
aesthetics because he played Bishop to
g5 and it was in this position that
Alexander Bishop resigned the game
unmoved 24 because there is nothing he
can do here so the rook is still under
on the back rank so you cannot use the
f1 secured the knife coverage the f2
squares so there are no sneaky moves
with the Queen what you can do is you
could capture the bishop but then you
clear the the c7 square for the Queen
for example if the bishop characters
just Queen to c7 check King to e8 and
now it's not of course anything rash but
Knight to d7 d6 checkmate you don't have
a you don't have a move and of course
the knight cannot be captured and if you
don't capture the bishop after Bishop to
g5 well there simply are no good moves
you can try to make a move or so but
there just isn't one yeah either the
rook or the Queen can come to c7 so
that's very unpleasant if you try to
prevent this for example with Bishop to
d8 covering the c7 square then it's even
even nicer its mate in one night the c5
checkmate the the pawn covers here Queen
covers here and also
the this efile so just a beautiful
miniature bye-bye guitar oh and this is
this is the kind of guy Grichuk is he
will not accept give back the pawn and
play an equal equal game he will rather
accept the challenge and here he will
present this beautiful game for us to
enjoy so it always takes two to create a
beautiful game here both guitar oh and
Goethe sure created this masterpiece for
all of us to enjoy
so there we have it I do hope you enjoy
that I would like to thank Thomas
million Dirk Martin Hall Schmidt and
Andrew Frick for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see soon our
continuing the coverage of the of the
Isle of Man chess tournament checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and of
course whatever else happens in the
chess world so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day